here is the twin starter
the right-hander comes in comes into
tonight with a five and three record as
era sits
at 3-7-2 his era this month though john
is 2.05 shoko akiyama will lead things
off
what a breaking ball what a filthy start
for jose carrillos one down in the first
i'm just telling you he has one of the
greatest breaks to his breaking ball and
the arm angle that he throws it
and it has that lateral late
back-to-back strikeouts to start the
night for barrios
now joey vada will dig in vato gets a
bat on the 1-1 but marwin gonzalez
with the hops and the snag and a one two
three inning
from barrios and the twins now tyler
mally we kind of talked about
this the three-headed monster is the
phrase we throw around with talking
about the reds
he gets lost in the discussion but he
has been really really
effective now nelson cruz with 3-1
he takes another ball
so two walks for mali in the first
two aboard for the twins well if you're
struggling throwing strikes you want
this guy at the plate i mean this guy
loves to swing
no two he goes up to get it up in the
zone there's a base hit in the center
field kepler was going back to second
so holt up at third the bases are loaded
for the bumba squad and if you were to
pick a player in the minnesota lineup to
face in this situation yes this is very
much pick your poison it would not be
byron buxton swings and misses at the
2-2
ticket punched and it's a big one for
o'malley two down a little bit of labor
here in the first for tyler malley
miguel ceneaux
the 1-2 malley goes upstairs and gets
him barnhart
loves it back-to-back punches to escape
the bases loaded jam for the red starter
josh donaldson has been removed from the
game
andrianza coming in josh donaldson has
left tonight's game with a
right calf cramp he's considered day
to day what's going to happen in moose's
at-bat here schmaltzy a
strikeout b home run c and in play out
where d he
just simply reaches base d that bat is
broken
shallow right center oh wow i want to
play
gonzalez that could have got me on the
board early you wouldn't have caught me
i would not have i definitely wouldn't
have been able to catch up to you
like marwan gonzalez caught up to that
that's beautiful baseball
there's galvez on second he's hoping to
come home and score the first run of the
game
and castiano's can he get the job done
he might drop a 3-2
change up here that would be a oh
interesting pitch selection
it's not in the rally yet but let's see
if it happens
fourth strikeout for barrios the
lead-off single to galves
no harm done minnesota bummer squad
loaded with offense
adrianza turning on one
off the wall kepler will round and score
minnesota breaks the ice and it's one
nothing we have michael lorenzon
in his hulking physique
entering the game 3-2 pitch to buxton
michael lorenzen
feeling it strikeout ends the third
bleed off walk
mike mustakas hit well in a center field
buxton going back makes the jump but
cannot make the catch
the moose is loose and it's 2-1
cincinnati oh
my i betcha buxton's kicking himself
thinking he jumped a little too early
one of the most athletic center fielders
second and third for minnesota
minnesota's feeling it
[Applause]
kepler gets underneath it on the left
side
playable and suarez closes it you heard
the
cry that was from michael lorenzen
pumped up to get out of that if you're
a fan of cincinnati reds you're well
aware of how this team has been
living in and or dying with the long
ball as freddie galvez has turned on one
and this one
is way gone kepler watches it go
and the solo home run pads the reds lead
now three
to one you could tell cincinnati knows
what they're playing for and how
important this game in the series is
there's a base hit into left field
akiyama hustling home
4-1 cincy the reds pad their lead in the
fifth
snow did advance into scoring position
now at second base for marwyn gonzalez
the number nine batter for minnesota
smacked into left field will ceno be
sent he will
it's a two-run game here's byron buxton
leading things off with the twins down
by two
oh shoot oh no training staff out
quickly to check on byron buxton
it is great to see bucks and back up
quickly so buxton
will exit the game right so iglesias is
the call that david bell
is making into the cincinnati bullpen
two runners in scoring position with the
twins down
by two in the bottom of the eighth
inning the bomba squad knows how to
rally
swung on and missed a strikeout
so two down now he's still not out of
the woods second and third two outs in
the bottom of the eighth minnesota down
by two
iglesias versus gonzalez the 3-2
lifted into center field going back
senzel
he's there points to the bullpen who you
can hear on the mics as iglesious
escapes the bottom of the eighth
major league debut for edward colina
mike mustakis
golfed into right field kepler
looks up and he will watch it go the
moose
in minnesota for a second time tonight
it's 5-2
first and third still nobody out freddie
galvez
a base hit into right field garcia will
score
the lead is four shogul akiyaba
that's a bullet in the center field fist
pumps from senzel
as the reds pad the lead we could be
covering a postseason clincher for the
cincinnati reds
it's simple for the reds right now win
tonight
and you're in and the reds can celebrate
because the 2020 hunt is complete and
for the first time
since 2013 there will be a reds october
they believed that they could be a team
that could make a deep run